on et entassés comme des bêtes dans
l'autobus et c'est un euphémisme que
j'utilise ici
vraiment c'est insupportable on est
entassé et plusieurs et je prends
l'autobus à au deuxième arrêt après le
métro a donc imaginé un peu il ya
plusieurs personnes qui n'arrivent même
pas à le prendre et c'est quotidien ces
quotidiens c'est devenu insupportable et
c'est un facteur de stress énorme avant
d'aller arrivée au travail
on est toujours stressé est ce qu'on va
pouvoir prendre notre transport est ce
qu'on va pouvoir arriver à l'heure à
notre travail
donc ça devient vraiment surtout ces
dernières années je vous dirais les deux
dernières années sans particulièrement
difficile au niveau de l'autobus mais au
métro si vous remarquez si vous prenez
votre auto de votre métro c'est
l'achalandage est énorme la population
c'est la population s'accroît à montréal
et on dirait que le moyen de transport
ne suis pas ne s'adapte pas à la
population qui s'accroît chaque année et
ça ça parait vraiment dans le transport
en commun